Brayan go get milkshakes you having
people have acid I care because I don't
know if there's acid in that milkshake
it's a salt it's battery I would never
encourage no I'm not scared of
milkshakes I think somebody throws a
milkshake is a party but I but I do have
a problem with someone invading its
personal time for the latest installment
of change my mind where we rationalize
our positions on controversial topics
full interviews unedited with regular
people in their full context this week
we decided to revisit the topic of hate
speech given that it's the recent
controversy du jour where's the line
between freedom of speech and who
decides this is hate speech this past
week we made a change in how we handled
hate speech we have many many different
reviewers they will do a review again
there are lots of different videos
produced by Stephan Bonnar who's been a
long time but is we need better
framework set on what does hate speech
what's not hate speech that's what it is
it's hate speech the problem is that
hate speech is not so clearly defined
least of all by big tech so we decided
to take to the Google offices in Austin
to get some answers the whole day ended
up being surprisingly civil and
productive seems common ground is easy
to find on this topic so before we move
on how do you define hate speech if at
all and should any speech be regulated
comment below oh hey look here's someone
who actually works for Google your
mother missed it change my mind though
if you disagree
and because it's not a real thing is
legally not a recognized turn yes paid
speech is not a real thing now if we you
know we can talk about what people
consider me the offensive speech but
what do you think hate speech is I go
how would you define it can you seem
surprised that it's not real no I didn't
understand
yeah well I'm saying people use a term
hate speech a lot doesn't exist or even
just does anything of a you know hate
speech it's not a real thing it's a term
that's used that people think there's
some kind of a carve-out with the First
Amendment the ability to speak freely
hate speech is not a qualifier it's not
a real thing right yeah it's not right
right no that's that's the issue but a
lot of people think that either it is or
that it should be no any levels no not
not outside of the current
constitutional parameters that we have
on the freedom of speech well you like
sit down and talk about it would just be
five minutes if you'd like to that'd be
great
thanks so much
all right thank you very much Felicia
we should okay I appreciate it we
already kind of cookie
I wasn't stalking you I saw it right
there I did it didn't require a lot of
Columbo work no we kind of you know I
hope you already understand my position
that it's not a real thing but you sound
surprised
when you asked me if I think it should
be enforceable or legislated you know I
don't seems that you you maybe do so I
look at it this way there's for example
example drinking alcohol is legal sure
but it is illegal to drink alcohol to
the point where you can harm their self
or harm others
sure another example is seatbelts it's
you have to require to wear seatbelts
because now wearing them could be
harmful yeah so I see
hey speech in that same category but the
hard part is where I'm not 100% sold on
that it should be illegal to have a
species there's no clear line where you
can see okay once you've crossed this
point now you've done something wrong I
would I would say that right now there
is a clear line and we have the First
Amendment and the only exceptions would
be issues that are already crying
for example physical threats of violence
or committing slander right so people
often use an example you can't yell fire
in a crowded theater a tree there's a
fire well you can't do is lie that
causes actual physical harm that's
already a crime right so but again the
Supreme Court is affirm that those are
completely separate issues because those
are already criminal acts regardless of
speech there is no differentiation
between offensive speech in eight speech
so if you would think that it needs to
be taken further than where it currently
is with the First Amendment I guess what
would you qualify as harmful speech and
that's that's the hard part of
differences define what is that point
where you cross the line for this top of
the page speech did you write is defined
already legally defined but if you were
going to
something onto it how would you add it
oh it's not legal it's only legal to
really define and the Supreme Court said
it's not a thing all right the examples
you gave have already been gonna be
examples of slander or of direct threat
by freedom of speech kind of has its
boundaries but if I were to we'll see if
artists that come up with an example
it's just a hard one it's essentially
when people say things that can kind of
gather the masses to do something that's
problematic for instance if a very
popular figure word is to say oh this
person I don't like this guy you know
what you should go out you should go out
and kill them well that's a crime so
that's already this line is it crime
that's a crime yeah because as an actual
offense you are calling people to a
violent action against somebody okay you
give me an example of hate speech that
isn't a crime that people want to be
defined as a crime because that's really
all I subjective terms I like like a
projectile in word right people want
that to be illegal well things like
different people of different
definitions so offensive slur so people
have that the reason I ask is because
there have been people who said well
speech that is harmful and they haven't
used examples like yeah I would respect
that someone saying hey kill this person
but even someone saying hey I want you
to throw a milkshake on his head that's
a crime right we both agree that if
someone does it they follow your
instruction but people have given you
examples like other minorities or
speaking in a way that's offensive give
you an example saying you should kill
Felicia because she's black let's assume
as a racist right that's obviously wrong
but someone who's a racist saying I
don't like falesha because she's black
I think that's horrible I disagree with
him but he does have the right to say it
I don't think that should be illegal at
all okay Susan was opinion not causing
anyone any harm it's a slightly richer
their definitions now it's not it's just
someone's opinion right because it seems
to me that what you believe is not
committed
in the realm of speech is basically what
we already have laws preventing an
actual happen so it sounds to me like
I'm talking about this you wouldn't want
any addendums any additional as far as
just simply calling someone either a
name or having an opinion about someone
or something no matter how offensive no
matter how it is okay I agree completely
Thank You Felicia
appreciate it thank you sit down common
ground the day was shaping up nicely
then Kiefer Sutherland from Lost Boys
showed up
a pushing a hard work worth a lot sum of
all the rights but never once did I ever
have such as that well I'm 14 half years
I'm glad to hear that you know my
brother went to UT and that wasn't the
case and when we visited UT that wasn't
the case with both professors and
students who wanted as families and then
and then statistically I'm glad to hear
that's the case but you guys there are
38 percent of college campuses have no
conservative professors across this
country zero zero and I'm even bring
that we have it up at the web site and
so you can check the source let's the
student with okay do you have any
sources for anything that you're
planning do I know you don't either
well I do they're posted right now where
you can go and see them so I want to
make sure this is it's something I don't
have it right with me well it is because
you said you wanted to call bullsh made
an anecdotal claim so the empirical the
verifiable shows that there's a clear
imbalance of political world views
expressed in college campus to the point
where there's 30 percent of college of
campuses no Conservatives whatsoever and
then of course in the on the campus that
do have conservative professors they are
in a very significant minority if you
disagree with that you disagree with the
sources that's fine but I would present
them and say that's something concerning
again there's nowhere else do you see
that imbalance of worldly you don't see
it in any other work place outside of
academia the entertainment industry in
media
yeah okay week before but I would
would you mind moving a little closer so
we can kill you on my buns off what do
you mean by almost any means that I
support I support multiculturalism is
great but we should write you know kind
of sure I don't think it's the job of
the state to tell you what to say yeah
[Music]
you know not what you said by almost any
means necessary
yeah does that extend beyond speech do
that expended I mean first off what is
it that people would have posed as far
as what I'm doing well I'm not talking
about you okay okay I'm not I'm not like
seeing yeah I wouldn't be good idea okay
well they're openly genocide sure you
know I'm kind of like Richard Spitzer
people like that yeah
well you know but the thing is I've been
accused of racism I've been accused of
homophobia and sexism without any sort
of qualifications - so the challenge
then becomes against speech can be
combated combative with speech now with
physical force well I can't
about whatever yeah actually so I'm not
gonna speak to like with you say for
River admittedly right taking the time
what I'm saying is if I your worldview
right you said that it's kind of eerie
we're using by almost any means
necessary you know I have had physical
acts of violence both committed and
threatened against me because of
ill-conceived notions positions that I
don't even hold right so do you see the
danger in saying if someone is an
extremist if someone is a racist or a
sexist or homophobic you have the right
as a private individual by any means
necessary by almost any means necessary
to correct them so you see the problem
with that because we right or wrong by
the way with things like that I fully
support by enemies violence so so what
what would constitute I guess what would
justify violence against example
violence or calls yeah
well listen that's already illegal so
for example to call to call for the
extermination of black people or to call
for the extermination of Jews right
that's illegal saying I hate Jews or I
hate black people which we're not saying
right because you've already mentioned
violence on to make sure I understand I
don't think that's something that
warrants acts of physical violence I
think about that what speech do you
think do you disagree do you think
someone's saying I dislike black people
I think they're inferior do you think
that warrants physical violence and the
challenge now is of course everyone's
called a Nazi or racist or a homophobe
who disagrees with people on the left
and then you know that you it seems like
you're sensible you agree that that's a
problem and that's actually used as a
call to violence far more than someone
using a racial epithet in the joke right
people say that person's a Nazi that
person's a racist that person is a
homophobic people are having acts of
violence committed against them all the
time Reagan milkshake you having people
have acid because I'm not there's acid
in that milkshake it's a salt it's
battery I would never encourage no not
stared in milkshakes I think somebody
throws a milkshake is important but I
but I do have a problem with someone in
that he's a nice person
no that's not I don't you're saying I'm
not scared of milkshakes but I I think
people should be concerned with
milkshakes because they don't know
what's in that milkshake and I think
that if you go around and you saw
something of someone or you see that
that's okay you warn an ass-kicking
right so would you drink with those same
rules if someone throws in milkshakes
they should get their asses kicked or at
least its deserved but I don't sleep
sure yeah yeah yeah but the problem with
it again is just because someone's
racist or has speech II don't like you
you really you're not entitled to commit
acts of physical violence and that seems
to be a common thread with like the aunt
if I left today
and that's a real problem well here's
the thing is that's something I believe
that I would be willing to accept the
legal consequences of that short
situation so I understand so you want to
operate outside the bounds of the law
because you okay I just agree I called
that criminality okay so but III would
agree with your right to say whatever
you want to say regardless of how
offensive now if you were to call
someone to an action of violence for
example call someone - whether it's
milkshake or a salt or punch or stabbed
somebody yeah I would report you okay
that because that lready of the crime so
I think it's still remarkably consistent
you can say something that's super
offensive don't care as bad as you want
but committing an act of violence or
calling someone act of violence that's a
real problem and I don't think that
plays a role in today's political
discourse but I appreciate your
intellectual consistency on absolutely
thank you man I appreciate it thank you
for something even though we disagree
right thank you okay started off hostile
but didn't end half badly
thanks Keefer now for the first time
ever given the current topic I wanted to
bring in my half-asian lawyer Bill
Richmond to try his hand what's going on
man bill nice to meet you Edwin my
co-financier games on the internet okay
so I how can you possibly believe that
hitch speech isn't real when we just had
white supremacist walking our streets
literally if they were if there were
less laws with guns and and the way the
way it is now they would probably take
advantage of people of color the gays
questions the question we're here for so
let me let me kind of expand on what the
topic is on waters don't get me wrong I
know this is America
we get we have a lot of freedoms no it
is biggest free country in the world but
yeah we have
very fringe problematic issues I hate
using that word problematic issues that
probably either may need to be addressed
or or maybe will just go away with time
but I really don't think they're gonna
go away with time they're just gonna
probably become more fringe or maybe
more extreme so if they become more
fringe that means they become less keep
in mind this was all in good fun and a
half Asian lawyer bill Richman knows how
to handle himself hello mr. Jones we
would like to mrs. Jones I'm not sure
what way I want to appropriately respect
you and the fact that Edwin and I were
having a conversation about why hate
speech isn't real and he's trying to
change my mind so we're gonna let him
chase you call me mrs. Jones I will mrs.
Jones thank you all right so so so one
of the kind of question we were getting
to is like what is what are we actually
talking about here and so what to give
you the framework that we're talking
about is we have a framework in this
country of the Supreme Court precedent
and our laws that says if it's an
emergency we have a restriction on
speech so that's if it's a direct
imminent serious harm and viewpoint
neutrality so you can have laws against
vandalism but they're not dependent on
what the vandalism is so what the
message is crimes perjury fraud that
type of thing and so hate speech is
speech for example Canada Europe or
France that goes beyond that that says
if it's offensive if it talks about race
in an offensive or demeaning or
fear-inducing way then it should be
punishable either by fines or jail or
otherwise and what I'm saying is that
the platform that we already have is
adequate to cover the examples that you
just gave so if someone is directly
inciting violence if they are carrying
guns in a way that intimidates or
brandishing weapons those aren't
protected their types of speech they're
already limited and regulated within our
system so why would we need more
regulation than that
but don't you don't you feel like if we
had like a Internet Bill of Rights at
least to generally give us a uniform
like for like Google say like a uniform
like governmental law saying like this
is hate speech this is not a speech and
then this is the Terms of Service
against all private entities wouldn't
that be better for for protecting like
say you as a creator so you're right
clarity of rules would make everyone's
participation in our planet because this
is this is the the media this is the
meat modern media this is the modern
newspaper the newspapers dead radios
dead who use radio anymore no but maybe
maybe mrs. Jones but I mean I feel like
that would be something at least the
minimum that we need the internet bills
or how would you define what the hate
speech is that I mean don't weaving the
only thing I can say that would define
hate speech at this point would be
anyone like we do have white supremacist
in the country they do want it they want
to express their speech as kill killed
the gay killed the the brown man care
and that that is a thing that that that
seems very very pretty sure many Allah
racist and it's usually most
confrontations are between two non
racist people so that's usually and it's
just have he at the moment issue and
stuff like that and that's you see time
and time and again in the work place
time and time and again before the
definition how would we ask people to
apply the law if it's not just a
subjective statement if it's just how
offended is it and perhaps the other
question would be is who is going to
decide because if we give the government
the power then that means Trump decides
now and then whoever wins the next
election or the election after that they
get to decide what it is and why should
we give I mean I'm in the power inside
what I feel like I feel like it should
evolve over time things do change people
change what do you believe I do believe
for the left they tend to change the
goalposts for the case of like Carlos
Massa he uses
as a term brother I don't I don't really
agree with that as a fellow gay man it's
really really like boggles my mind that
we would really claim a word that was
used against gay people for so long
right - so it's it's just me being the
liberal eating a liberal in that friend
so I don't know I think you're being
logically consistent I mean to say wait
a minute this was a word that we find to
be offensive so we should stop using the
word and I think that's kind of my point
is to say if you ignore viewpoint
neutrality then you can then you can go
out and say it's okay and then we have
like the I double of the trying to
reform those words and for him it
doesn't look so problematic but right
now the person says like the n-word or
something it will be problematic
so I don't know it's it's really hard to
tell like what line do we need to draw
especially for to YouTube frame because
I'm a big fan of YouTube got it ah I
don't watch your channel I'm sorry but I
am subbed to you I do watch on occasion
it just depends you're you can you kind
of are taboo so in my friend
so I mean well let me kind of conclude
on this point and let mrs. Jones do what
he wants to do here do you think that we
should is it your point that we give to
the extent that the First Amendment
doesn't allow for a hate sweeps law
should we amend the First Amendment to
allow the decisions we need to make a
bill in an I felt like it really needs
to be addressed these are issues that
that kind of like that uniform because
what happens is I am on Twitter and I
watch this for like the longest time
period of time the goalpost changes and
right one it's which it changes YouTube
it changes so it's really hard to
determine where where where the lines
are and with YouTube being so vague
sometimes they're like you're your gym
doughnut eyes and in situations where
it's targeted harassment I can
understand for Carlos masa I do
understand not so much the gate let's be
gay thing even though that's pretty
shitty
offensive offensive okay but that's but
I do care about the anchor baby that is
kind of like a little bit more further a
more wavy past that might be that might
be the norm for civil conversation even
in in our day of age yeah I don't really
know Carlos masa very well sure and I
don't know his background very well I'm
pretty sure I'll see something on
Twitter I don't know yeah well for those
who are trying to listen and haven't
been able to one thing that I had said
that I definitely agree with this the
constant shifting of the goalposts and
something we talked about earlier that
it's hard for anyone whether you're on
the left or the right to know what
creators can do on social media
platforms if the goalposts keep moving
so at the very least cependant
separate setting aside our views we can
at least agree let's get some clarity
from these platforms on what the rules
are is that fair yeah I agree
all right especially on the YouTube
front and wonderful thank you it was
great talking you guys can we get a
round of applause for ID for coming out
here tonight
thanks half-asian lawyer bill Richman
now time for this Zee I'm Adrian Adrian
a nice to meet you so you are upset
about a limitation of speech like
ideologically so let me now let me sort
of state it so we understand exactly the
premise hate speech is not real it's not
a real thing
legally it's not recognized as a real
thing there are no exceptions to the
First Amendment regardless of how
offensive the speech is and I of course
think that's a good thing if you
disagree then on that premise
this is um so it's about the First
Amendment
what exactly what actions by Google are
you objecting to well I'm not talking
about Google right now I'm talking about
hate speech is a term which has been
thrown around quite a bit and it's not a
real thing okay but would you agree that
there's like unfair censorship
ideologically going on on social media
in the internet you know I wouldn't use
the word necessarily censorship because
censorship would typically involve a
role of government but I certainly would
say yeah unfair treatment and uneven
application of the laws on social media
yeah and it's and it's been done so
under the guise often a paid speech
which isn't a real thing but so you're
framing the First Amendment thing but
what you directly I feel like I'm a
little confused here what you're totally
objecting to is I'm assuming the like on
public forum this is on the internet
essentially really unnecessarily I mean
we can talk about that we can definitely
talk about that I think that what's used
as kind of a I guess sort of a fulcrum
for that is the idea that what we're
adapting our guidelines for ought to
include more expansive I guess sort of
examples of hate speech is what they
it's very very vague it's very hard to
navigate those rules so before we get to
that you know there is of the United
States law which freedom of speech is
absolute there are no exceptions there
are no exceptions for hate speech and so
then the onus is on perhaps you or
people at Google if they say well we're
going to change our rules to include
more hate speech even though we know
there haven't been violations of
guidelines then the onus is on them to
define what hate speech is whoever says
hate speech is a thing the onus is on
you to define what hate speech is
because it's not so you feel responsible
for corporation
dictate public forums to use legal
terminology like hate speech and it's
like de-facto censorship well I'm not
saying its de facto censorship at that
point but using the term hate speech
saying we're going to create new
guidelines based around hate speech and
it's not defined I think that's a
problem because it's not a real thing it
just seems so abstract it to me like
what if they just called it something
different they just said like things we
don't like aren't allowed on our
platform I would have no problem with
that if they said offensive speech or
speech that we disagree with as a
company is not allowed in our platform
or are not allowed on our publishing
platform I would have no problem with
that so you disagree with the term the
use of the term hate speech I disagree
with the use of the term hate speech
because it's not a real thing I don't
think and maybe you can clarify your
position if you disagree on that first
step right whether you think hate speech
is a real thing if you think hate speech
should be regulated and then as it
relates to Google YouTube listen they
enjoy the legal protection of platforms
right now and that they're not liable
for things that are posted on their
platforms and that's because they're
seen as an open forum an open Town
Square now the difference between that
and let's say for example my web site
different from that let's say the New
York Times web site is they are a
publisher right not everyone can write
for the New York Times the New York
Times is clear about that so they don't
enjoy the protections of not being
liable for what they write YouTube
Google Facebook right now they enjoy the
benefits of being regulated as a
platform or similar to a public utility
without following those same rules so if
they said we are a publisher and we are
pushing a narrative and we even though
we recognize hate speech is not a real
thing we like to include it in our
company code of conduct and we want to
get rid of people we disagree with that
would be fine but that's not what
they're doing so you feel like if they
want to dictate what is shown on their
platform then they should be held to the
senders of a publisher not a platform of
a platform not a publisher yes
okay yeah that makes sense yeah well I
just think they need to decide on that
front I don't really have any strong
opinions on Censorship I was just
curious about the corporate versus a
governmental aspect of a lot of because
a lot of people do compare like social
media censorship to government
censorship which I don't really think is
an OPS comparison I don't necessarily
think it's an apt comparison until you
look at them enjoying protections from
the legal system right or if you look at
them receiving any kind of tax
incentives or any kind of subsidies
which you know we're not really
necessarily talking about in the case of
Google but certainly incentives to
regulate them as a platform I think the
first step I would say is this they need
to sit in a court of law
they need to declare legally whether
they are a big private publisher in
which case they can deep platform anyone
they want treat people however they want
based on point of view or if they're a
platform in which case they do not have
the right to do that right now the
guidelines are very vague and that's a
term that's often thrown around you know
hate speech that's really used as a
political weapon the silenced voices you
disagree with and that's why certainly I
think it's irrefutable that it should
not play a role in our society at large
the idea of hate speech laws and I think
if someone is going to declare that as
part of the policy in their platforms
it's their duty to define what it is and
they haven't there anything there with
which you disagree coming sense no I
wasn't sure about your premise because I
was confused by the location for a
Google office yes well obviously they
have the recently I was a subject of
some controversy where they yeah they
did they completely de monetize the
channel and they even though they
acknowledge that I didn't violate any
guidelines but someone complained from
Fox and as a result there have been
hundreds of channels where people have
made a living and obviously employ many
people that have been completely removed
from an ability to continue
make their living on YouTube and that's
a problem that's a problem people to
understand the rules it's a problem when
YouTube's removing people because in
some case it's not even a point of view
in some cases it's just because of
historical channels that have covered
World War two and the Nazis when YouTube
isn't clear about what the guidelines
are that's a problem to me when there's
a cozy relationship between government
and big tech and they're receiving
benefits without the equal
responsibility so then when do you say
that would need more indirect government
intervention into large corporations to
improve quality of life from citizens I
think the first well I think the first
step is then deciding what they are a
publisher a platform it hasn't been
answered yet and if they are a platform
we don't necessarily need new
regulations but we just need this for
them to follow the regulations already
in the books for public utilities and
platforms and if they say we're
publishers well then we just have the
ability to enforce the regulations that
are in the books for being them being a
publisher meaning they can be held
liable for everything that's published
on their platform so we don't really
need new regulations we have those
categories already it's just that
YouTube benefits from one category while
then implementing the rules of a
different category yeah this tech
companies are very sleazy yes yes they
are yeah so that's really just where I
line up which I hope make something has
been consistent that makes more sense
okay thank you very much thank you for
sitting down I appreciate it thank you
thanks Z great conversations all around
today but as always you can't please
everybody hey Jonathan so I've actually
watched a few of your I suppose I
watched a few of your videos yeah and I
think you're very entertaining okay I
haven't done much research on this topic
okay but I'm sure you've got a lot so we
spend the first like few minutes you
educated me on your stance well no let
me let me make it really pretty simple
it's about stating something in the
affirmative and then your if you are
feel passionately enough that my my
needs to be changed that's why you're
sitting in the chair
right well okay if not then you
shouldn't be sitting there but was that
the assumption that everyone brings that
they will succeed in changing your minds
will the attempt to but it could also be
they're trying to learn your position
well no change my mind as you change my
mind I'm not here to change your
you know but what if I'm trying to learn
your position yeah let me let me be
really clear that hate speech is not a
thing it's not real
what are we defined to be hit to be hate
speech yeah oh I hate speech
what do you define to be pain speech you
know but you're you're making a
statement here yeah well I don't
it's not it's not a real thing it's
legally not recognized so but what's
what's not the real thing the Supreme
Court has affirmed several times if
there is no carve out for anything
called hate speech in the United States
okay so any speech no matter how
offensive no matter how hateful yeah in
its rhetoric it's not identified as hate
speech it's protected under the First
Amendment okay so I'm actually not here
to disagree with you on your on your
premise sure I'm here to just make a
critique short of like the presentation
style okay
so I've heard it argued many times and
very convincingly that it would be a
slippery slope for the government to
regulate a subset of speech that people
find to be offensive as hate speech
right okay so here's a clear example
suppose that we have different standards
for what we consider to be hateful as I
think you just described in a previous
conversation sure and some people say
well this subset of like semantic usage
I find to be offensive as someone says I
disagree who should be the arbiter
between those two sets and who should
decide what the punishment should be
yeah so obviously to make my spirits
hard you want to continue I'm gonna
answer you no one no one right so
actually I agree with you but here's the
critique that I hope you can address I
think there's things that we find the
society to be hurtful
okay and obviously not unanimously and
maybe even actually just a minority of
people but still quite a few people and
by vocalizing how it's so arbitrary and
destructive for the government to
regulate that kind of speech the way
which we vocalize that could actually do
a lot of harm okay so here's an example
suppose that I were to use a racial slur
against Asian minorities and then I say
well technically the way we interpret
that slur and the way we process that is
pretty subjective moreover if we allow
the government to define this subset of
slurs as so heinous that we can punish
it by law okay then we actually face an
issue because they're the ones doing the
defining and then they can Barbra truly
increase what falls in that category
sure in a way that's harmful Society I
agree
but suppose I also go on YouTube
these people are extremely stupid and
advocating for the government to hold
this position there's a way in which
that's insensitive to people advocating
for the government told what position
the position that we should regulate
this subset of speech is paid for okay
so I think we're saying someone who goes
on YouTube forgive me I want to make
sure I understand yeah it sounded like
you were saying someone who goes on
YouTube and says that Asian people are
stupid no no okay I'm saying that
suppose I'm a person who observes Asians
being labeled with this racial slur okay
and then I say inferior and whatever
whatever the terminology is right and I
say to them hey the way that this is
being designated albeit offensive should
not be categorized as a government in
any legal terms for because of the
slippery slope that will lead us down
right but if suppose I also say that in
a way that's very dismissive of people
who hold a position and not considerate
of the particular viewpoint that they
have that itself that dismissiveness and
the lack of sensitivity I feel like can
do more harm than good so I think
there's a more nuanced position to be
held which is saying as I'm saying now I
think the government regulation has a
lot of flaws and therefore I agree with
you that the government shouldn't
regulate in the way that you're
describing but I think the way in which
you advocate for the position sure
against government regulation can be
more sensitive and nuanced okay then I
think there's often help so what's the
you said yet a critique that was the
critique that you think it's not nuanced
well I think that it's not sensitive and
not nuanced in like yeah okay so you
think that simply stating a position the
affirmative that it's factually accurate
which we both agreed that hate speech
isn't a real thing in the United States
and you're welcome to sit down and
change my mind in a long-form unedited
interview where I just let you spoke for
borderline a soliloquy yeah how much
more nuanced or fair sensitive could it
could one gas no but there's a way in
which you can be dismissive of people
maybe not in this specific context okay
right now you're making a very strong
point to hear me out which I appreciate
but I think just in general in the
aggregate there's a certain tone and a
certain disposition that you can set a
normative stance on in the way you
conduct yourself maybe not just
interviews but just in general you know
that is not sensitive or nuanced
and I think that could be an you like
that word nuance so maybe like something
so just this is a personal critique
right
correct well no actually I think you're
pretty funny okay actually like watching
your videos but I think generally like
people who agree with what you say and
also I think occasionally you can be
mortalis then is called for okay
and so maybe like in this pretty great
should be very kind yeah but there's a
general callousness that can pop up here
and there which I think there's more
harm than good like like what why don't
watch that many videos oh yeah well then
maybe that's why you think I'm funny
yeah II haven't seen enough of it could
be yeah you just talked with my wife
she'll tell you it's not okay well I you
know I appreciate you sitting down but I
can't really address any critique that
sounds to be somewhat personal based on
me being callous if you haven't watched
the content and can't give me any
examples okay so he's absolutely I
apologize here's why that's it's not a
full rebuttal because I was not a
rebuttal um things I can't address it if
you were if you can't actually you can't
address it because of other people who
brought up to you that they don't like
the way in which you demean certain
groups right yeah I'm sure they call you
callous so I don't actually have to make
that argument myself it's already being
made I'm just saying there may be some
validity to that what they're calling
for that's an appeal to popularity
fallacy it doesn't mean oh no it's not
what you said is nobody if some people
say that what I've said is offensive
right that doesn't mean that what I say
is offensive no actually I'm not saying
what you're saying is offensive what you
just said is you're being too vague in
addressing the critique you should watch
more of my content my response is there
are people who have watched your content
and they brought up maybe not in that
exact term okay that they find you to be
callous yeah and their response which I
think could be too drastic might be we
should outlaw this we should ban you we
should take sort of drastic action I'm
not saying that that's a valid response
for the exact reason that you've
specified earlier in earlier videos yeah
what I'm saying is that there's a
certain sensitivity that you can have in
addressing your critique of people who
want to like make it illegal to say
certain things that we call hate speech
right and that sensitivity would be nice
we're not nice actually it's too big of
a word it might win you more actually
I'm sure you people like the fact you're
more callous I think okay let me
rephrase this way it's such a normal
stance about being callous which I don't
think is a good thing right
we want comedy to be sensitive well
I think in your case there's a way in
which you know actually I don't know if
I call this a critique of comedy because
there's a way in which critiquing people
in general and actually making it so
that you can't critique people makes
them making them protected it's actually
just service to them because we say
they're actually too much of a victim
for us to address them in the way we
dress others so I'm not saying that I am
saying though why don't we make a
critique of a legal system even though
it is involves comedy we might do more
harm than good
by the callousness with which we do it
well I wasn't critiquing the legal
system no but if I brought it up you
would have so we were talking about
first off yeah when we talk about the
legal system I was talking about hate
speech as it defined the only way it's
ever been addressed but so the Daniell
were telling me you came out up to a
personal particular by the way listen
you may think my you know the comedy is
callous on a late-night show that's your
right to think so and that's right for
anyone else I think so but I don't
really know why that matters well so
here's here's a key obvious because I do
think it's important I just talked about
this earlier sure you're not super
familiar with my content yeah right so
what you're experiencing right now which
this has been respectful yeah which has
been nuanced sensitive yeah okay this is
how we do all of the change my minds
this is how we do all of the segments
that are long-form debates with people
who come onto the program right context
does determine your behavior doesn't
determine your values but for example me
telling a joke at a late-night comedy
club yeah which I do is going to be a
different kind of behavior than me for
example having someone write program to
debate good it's going to be different
right contextually then how I'll behave
with someone like you've given me that
letting go so again if we say well on a
second this is okay what we're doing now
but in the context of comedy it needs to
be more nuanced it needs to be more
sensitive that's fine that's a perfectly
valid personal critique to have I just
don't agree with it okay so I think
so yeah I think okay go ahead but I
don't think I just don't think we're
going to agree I don't think the comedy
needs to be sensitive or nuanced so I
think it needs to be funny that's my
only qualifier for comedy I think
there's so actually the reason I bring
this up is not because I think in
general Carly should be sensitive
nuanced I think it's just when we
advocate for a lack of government
regulation there's a way in which we can
do it that normalizes certain callous
behavior and thinking which is it's not
a good thing
so you said specifically that in these
sort of long-form conversations are very
sensitive which I agree with they've
also said that there's certain I guess
like concerns and priorities we should
have when we think of comedy which is is
it funny not is it nuanced or sensitive
and I think that there's a way in which
the importance of a topic can actually
branch over into those two realms so the
importance of this topic here is like
what is the logical underpinnings of
this statement which we actually really
haven't addressed because that's not
really what I came to talk to you about
and sure because there's a strong
argument for your statement yeah and
therefore I don't want to attack what I
don't have a strong counter are you
before you set a personal fatigue right
it's very vague well it's actually not
vague let me say it again and hopefully
sure you can point to me where it is
vague
yeah so when you critique government
regulation there's a way in a manner in
which you critique it that can do more
harm than good in its callous nature
what if you're not critiquing government
regulations what if you're advocating
government regulation that can also be
callous okay I'm not saying that I'm in
favor of government regulation it's then
that's irrelevant as a pre-qualifier
right you're just saying people
shouldn't be callous no but I'm talking
about this specific of regulation which
so often these kinds of debates what
you'll do is you'll bring up specific
laws and then critique them in a very
compelling way I'm just saying I don't
actually don't think of these long form
of debates probably you do it as harshly
but maybe in your late-night stand-up
and I think in in other ways there's a
way you can be callous making that
critique that such a normative stance
sure that I don't think it's good
okay so you just you personally don't
like the way that I do comedy no but I
also think this is a more nuanced
position that can be voiced as you
described people who hold logically
inconsistent and middlee logically for
some citizens there's a way in which you
can do that in a more kinda manner I
guess for the sake of comedy
sounds like gonna be a lot of fun at
party so I appreciate it we do because I
think we're going around in circles here
here's what I would love to see you know
I would I would love to see you do kind
of what you're talking about you
practice what you preach and do some
comedy in a very nuanced sensitive way
that gets people to laugh and people
enjoy I I think what we've been doing a
couple final points here for a while but
I do appreciate it now and I'm sorry
that you think of it I'm callous I've
tried to not be here in this case and I
understand your point I understand your
point I just don't care you're still
here I'll chalk that up to our fantastic
retention rate if you enjoyed this
installment of change my mind please
consider clicking on one of these boxes
I can't see where they are to watch
another installment or I'd highly
recommend considering joining my club at
ladders credit.com slash mug Club not
only do you get access to the full daily
show in content that you can't see here
on YouTube but because we were recently
entirely demonetized it's the only thing
that keeps this kind of content going so
we appreciate your support as public
enemy number one of youtube we're
learning how to navigate these waters
maybe if we were more effective at
transgender makeup tutorials or more
advertiser friendly podcast about
transgender makeup tutorials